Robert De Niro is reaching that stage in
his career the cash grab stage called
the Harrison Ford oh God that was 20
years ago well no it's getting worse so
uh I'm gonna I'm gonna show you these
these two Italian Legends merch because
I know you have like Italian movies
right you're a big mob guy hey how come
he's never done like you know like
there's so many movies where
uh people like you know will star with
their kid how come his kids never been
in a movie with him it started oh
because you can't have a believable
Italian gangster having a mulatto kid oh
they wouldn't accept it on the count of
the racism Sons of Anarchy will juice
would have been fine a super weird the
juice was so worried about that it was
not even a big deal like it was the
stupidest guy in the biker gang in 2023.
he killed people and he's also the only
guy that knows how to work their
security cameras relax they're not gonna
just fire you because you're black
okay
this movie's called about my father now
who do you obviously De Niro's the dad
who do you think the Sun is
um think of Italians Donald Glover
Italian
I thought you were asking me to think of
somebody would be a good representation
of his actuals yeah
Blake Griffin
uh Colin Kaepernick
Lenny Kravitz
yeah Dante Martin
uh so guess Italian actor about the age
it would be De Niro's kid
I use the word actor loosely
the guy from Doogie Howser all right
let's check it out
my parents are inviting us to the summer
oh my God is that Sebastian maniscal you
better [__] believe it is you better
[__] believe it is
yeah better [__] believe it is can
you believe it Robert de niros my father
is this gonna be the whole movie yeah
I'm a place for the big Fourth of July
weekend I can't leave my father oh my
God it's gonna be the whole movie I I
told you Sebastian Maniscalco is one of
the easiest Impressions to do all you
gotta do is talk like this
[Laughter]
My Father Robert de niros my father
that's gonna be the whole movie
I'm excited for it aren't you this is
the
you know it's funny because Daniel's
going to be this guy who doesn't get it
he doesn't get the modern stuff he
doesn't get it remember when I did the
MTV Awards
it was controversial I remember that
yeah but he was like oh my God we're
gonna cancel him and I was like they
tried to manufacture outrage to get his
career going and it's like I'm pretty
sure most people weren't offended by you
being at the MTV Awards I'm pretty sure
most people that age were like who is
this guy who's this first summer was
this who's this [__] Guido that
traveled here from back in time
you're right he's like who's this
throwback 80s Guido that's a good point
he's not even a modern Guido he's an old
time ago this cancer culture
he's basically you know it's Sebastian
Maniscalco is he's just a calm daddy
Magic from aw yes
since we have to say goodbye to your
dear Mother and you'll want to leave me
to burn the spot because alone oh my God
this movie's gonna be so good I'm
excited Frozen add this one to the list
about my father yeah starring Robert De
Niro and really Italian Pete Davidson
[Laughter]
I don't even have butthole eyes
my dad didn't die on 9 11.
no like seriously spaghetti and
meatballs and like papity poopy I don't
even know how I get to [__] all these
hot girls from the hilarious from the
hilarious mind of Sebastian maniscoca
you hear this ladies he's wearing
worried immigrant father's gonna make it
look like some kind of what immigrant
father you're born in the Bronx shut the
[__] up yeah you're not even doing a
good like like Boppity boopy accent you
should have at least got you you would
have been better casting Luigi Primo as
this guy's dad seriously
listen if we're gonna do this Dad you
gotta dial it down
what is this
that's
cause that's literally Sebastian's
entire act it is man it's so crazy
growing up Italian is it
idiots a lot of people have done it I'm
going to blow your mom around and my mom
with the spoon hit me with a spoon I'm
gonna tell you about my unique life
experience I'm from New York and my
family's Italian whoa I've seen that
one-man show before yeah yeah we have
what's next a Cuban in Miami that's
crazy no we'll have Pacino plan well
also in Italian's playing them but that
like but that would be like them
pitching Royce's show and being like all
right so you're Cuban your family lives
in Miami okay all right what's the show
what's the show though
like oh so I'm literally every
[__] in Miami oh cool great show
wow this is amazing look at his little
pants here it's called love and
affection then unlike you when you met
me at the delivery room you chose to
shake my hands because he's Italian oh
my God he really is just making doing a
set he's doing a set but like oh my God
so bad what else was I supposed to do we
just met
Sebastian I don't know how you're gonna
fit in
oh my God his name's Sebastian in the
movie too yeah
you know what movies by the way this is
I still agree with me you know a movie's
good
when the main character is named after
the actor uh-huh like you've seen those
movies back in the day where it's like
you know and like you know uh you know
David Witherspoon plays David in the
movie and it's like wow y'all [__]
just didn't even have a script dude they
do it like it's like Kevin Hart place
like Kevin Hurst yes exactly
oh my God no he plays Menace Robert De
Niro Salvo Maniscalco he's Sebastian man
he's himself in this oh my God wait so
this is so this is one man show the
movie
you know growing up around a bunch of
Italians in New York we had a bunch of
characters
there were so there was of course there
was of course the the mailman hey Tommy
we got a package for you it is guys it's
Loosely based on his life guys hey guys
you know my grandmother God bless her
soul she was quick as a pistol
and then you have to do the Grandma's
impression and he'd call her his Nona
you idiot he's Italian you dumbass
and Monona would go
she would pinch my cheeks and go when
are you gonna find the nice girl
Sebastian and I told her grandma I'm a
[__]
I'm so excited for this movie I can't
wait to watch it believe it or not
oh man dude since Gotti the papadee
boopy films are my favorite to do with
you guys yeah I know they're fun they're
so fun so much fun
don't these people have jobs they got
their money in the stock market not
managers but he's a stock market now I'm
already hearing my own impression they
got their money in the stock market what
is he doing Market thing can we get can
we get Robbie Goodwin to come on for
this please
yes we'll do it yes yes that'll be the
rift yes we will we will I will DM him
immediately after the show and release
is that durs from workaholic there on
the left is that homie from Workaholics
yeah it is
we really can't culturally blend in at a
golf course nobody does by the way by
the way they're doing the hack sweater
around the neck thing that nobody
actually does but that's what I mean
this is like every bad old premise like
hey how are these whops gonna get by at
the Country Club it's 2023 dude I
already paid the membership fee they
don't give a [__] they let you use in
there now all bets are off yeah
mar-a-lago's a mess now there's Jews and
blacks I mean it's just it's awful Laura
loomers has Chinese spies and Laura
loomeranging out it's a mess I'm
predicting it right now there's gonna be
a scene where they're all eating dinner
and the waspy boyfriend's there right
and you're gonna all you're gonna you're
gonna hear what do you mean you're full
exactly all right I'm making a
prediction sure there's an nft joke in
there no come on don't do this
one of the waspy people made all his
money on nfts it's gonna be all right or
how about this crypto in general how
about just crypto it might have got to
be an nft joke that's the hot joke
though that's the hot joke
well it was but it's a Sebastian
Maniscalco movie so whatever was hot a
year ago will be in the movie
but really he's such a [__] hack like
what happened when I hosted the VMAs and
my publicists tried to generate an
AstroTurf some controversy yeah about a
show nobody watches anymore nobody cares
only nft I know is a nice friggin
tiramisu
there's the joke there it is all right
add it to the script let's go hey what's
the matter this country club got an
espresso
I like that you do that I like that you
do the face too that's what sells it for
me he does the the confused Italian book
that says everything he sells every line
that way
you're at a golf course Italians
yeah they play golf too you [__]
[__] mind blown
we already did Caddyshack that was in
the [__] 70s you [__]
[Laughter]
remake
in a fraternity in college
yeah they let him in there too you
[__] what's next a black president
what a [__] hack premise and Italian
in America in 2023 I'm a real fish out
of what
the Jackoff
you're [__] Sebastian's killing me
bro
stolen this weekend because these people
love to blame the immigrants what
immigrants
Italians are more American than people
that live in America now what are you
talking about this is Doug he's learning
to be a Healer hello how much extra we
have to pay Robert De Niro just to be in
a movie where his wife is white
look at this taper taper clip it that
peacock it's a picture now
I love you these people are strange
they're birds for pets
are they gonna show the whole movie in
this three-minute trailer Jesus [__]
Christ that's just a bunch of God damn
people are weird they got birds for pets
birds are only for two things eating and
then holding while you do a walk and
talk only two things Birds afford
actually an Italian all we do first is
murder them
if you ask me
I was nervous to bring you here but I
didn't know you were going to spend the
whole time embarrassing me how could you
say that to your father Here We Go Again
everything I'm doing for you that I've
ever done for you is for your own good
hey man check it out I can die I'm
trying to make sure that you don't make
an ass out of yourself by trying to be
somebody you're not
oh my god oh [__] Sebastian your suit
it's Versace if you like it no you [__]
it's not up
um so he I'm to believe he didn't feel
his dick out like you know what I mean
no he didn't like you so you're you're
[__] dick and balls were out if [__]
was around your ankles and you're like
hey and they had to tell you that yeah
but then then what's the joke if he felt
that he did with demino joke
yeah I know it's fashion Maniscalco
movie I didn't come here expecting jokes
oh yeah
part remember when I took you to see
those Police Academy movies nobody was
laughing were they that's right being a
police is no laughing matter
I would love to make a phone
[Laughter]
what a trailer core version
we don't keep a lot of food here Amanda
scalco always finds a way to feed his
family
my father has an old Italian saying
family isn't one important thing it's
everything I can see outside of the
world of Sebastian Maniscalco right
um most normal people natural dialogue
would just be you know my my uh my
father has an old saying my grandfather
used to have this old saying like but in
a Sebastian manic scalco's entire act in
his entire uh I like to call it the
Maniscalco verse Oh the scalco verse I
like that really just you have to add
the adjective of Italian to everything
you know my Italian dad he's got an old
Italian saying that he learned in Italy
Italian we heard you we put this all
together from what we have in the
kitchen it's artichoke and poultry
absolutely
thank you
oh no date the peacock
they ate the peacock so what it is is
basically like get out but for Italians
so it's get out of here
it's called forget about it